all right the steelers have their six
super bowl trophies in the case they
traded their sixth round receiver to the
oakland raiders for a three and a five
we've talked about juju smith schuster
stepping up and taking over we've talked
about james washington a second round
pick a year ago possibly becoming a
better player but but really big picture
what do they do with this receiving core
you're taking away one of the best
receivers in the game you had a great
one-two combination with antonio brown
and juju smith schuster where do they go
from here chris yeah they're they're
going to have to reinvent reinvent the
wheel a little bit for what they want to
do and how they want to attack on the
offensive side of the ball i mean juju
smith schuster is one of the six or
seven best wide receivers in football so
at least they got him i think vance
mcdonald at the tight end position
really he he emerged last year i thought
as kind of like the new gronk the new
physical force who's amazing at run
blocking and when he catches the ball
over the middle not one guy's gonna
tackle him you need like three or four
guys to bring him down so they have that
you know hey running back position
they're pretty good they might add
something there too uh but samuel james
connor can both run and catch the ball
out of the back field you talked about
james washington and i'll say this again
you know dante moncrief moncrief that
was a good signing by them yeah not a
superstar but a good player who didn't
really get to show what he's all about
last year in jacksonville because they
had offensive issues as well and again
just like we talked about with the
buffalo bills mike the steelers at that
and what are they drafting at 21 i just
want to make sure i'm right 20th pick in
the draft they're right in the range to
where that second receiver in the nfl
draft will go the kid paris campbell
from ohio state i could see pittsburgh
loving him to be the new explosive
emmanuel sanders antonio brown's
whatever it may be ma you know i don't
think they're going to go marquis brown
the kid from oklahoma who would also be
in that conversation cousin of
entertainment i
anyone related antonio brown but my
point i don't think that's happening
they're amazing at drafting wide
receivers and i'm sure they got their
eyes on a few guys that could possibly
fill that void first second third round
yeah and you know i've asked kevin
colbert about that why do they seem to
find these great receivers in the mid to
late round if the drafting if he
downplays it whatever the secret is he's
not going to share it with us the secret
could be ben rothersberger for all the
the knocks he takes having a great
quarterback allows you to
rotate in receivers who can can more
easily get it done if the quarterback is
putting the ball right where it needs to
be chris yes exactly again i'm gonna i
say this a lot and i know big ben he's
not exactly mr role model perfect human
being off the field and he's not the
best teammate either i mean we know that
this is not just because antonio brown
there's been more people that have
complained about it ben roethlisberger
the teammate but i do think those
factors sometimes take away for how
special the player is on the field uh
and
i know you've heard me say this before
you might think i'm crazy you think i'm
crazy anyways but i believe big ben
roethlisberger is in the conversation
for like one of the 10 greatest
quarterbacks of all time and i know i
don't know everything but i know i watch
a lot of football in my life and i watch
quarterbacks a lot he is special and
when they show antonio brown highlights
damn the ball is on the money every time
whether antonio's covered or not it is
right between the eight and the four
every time so uh to your point i do
think people need to take that into
account maybe a little more than than we
all do
like larry fitzgerald said a couple of
weeks ago antonio brown may not realize
how good he has in playing with ben
roethlisberger and yes he's not a choir
boy he's not a model citizen he's not
exactly the easiest guy to get along
with he'll block you on twitter and if
you haven't checked i highly recommend
that if you have a twitter account pull
up underscore big ben seven and see if
you've been blocked because for some
reason just a bunch of random people who
have no connection to the media no
connection to the steelers no connection
to anything are blocked by big ben on
twitter wow all that said are you a
great quarterback
i'm blocked by him i'm blocked by odell
beckham i'm just wondering what point
antonio brown is going to block me i'm
surprised he didn't block me after i
tweeted yesterday that antonio brown was
late for his introductory press
conference so uh the steelers will move
forward with receivers i didn't mention
eli rogers he's back in the fold as well
right a guy who had 550 yards or so a
couple of years ago had a 100 yard game
against the ravens has shown some
potential had to torn acl at the end of
the 2017 season eventually came back
last year maybe he can make things
happen as well all right uh chris
you get your long weekend friday
saturday sunday no work for you
um we'll check out the latest edition
climate strike day climate strike day
and you know me i'm a supporter of the
climate change cause i mean it's a real
issue so i'm not coming to work screw
you mike sorry wait does that mean
wait a minute how does that how does
protecting the environment mesh with
burning a certain leafy substance well i
never said i was the perfect model
citizen in all ways but i do my best
okay i am human i am flawed but i still
am trying to fight the good fight here
so uh yes i you have an electric car i
do you have an electric car i try to
take i work yeah go ahead i worry about
the electric car because
i what happens if the electricity runs
out and do you know and like if you you
can't just pull over and get electricity
somewhere you can no that's what people
are missing too i mean here at nbc right
out here in the parking lot they have
electricity they have plug-ins for the
electric cars they're so when i go on my
tesla you can i can pull it up just like
gas stations on a navigation i can pull
up the charging ports to where yeah
you're not gonna fill up your full tank
of battery like the gas station in like
three or four minutes it might take 20
25 minutes to give you you know a big
boost of energy at some of these
charging stations but they're out there
and we need to grow them and continue to
grow this whole business because we got
to get away from gas powered cars and
all of those things that are polluting
our air
yeah but you know
nothing sounds like a gas guzzling i get
it but you know what kick it in and
people will get it
yeah if people will get in these
electric cars i have a lot of fun at the
stoplight with the guy that's in the
porch next to me and i go oh this
porsche all that gas he can't keep up
with my electric tesla zoo so people
would have fun driving these cars too
it's not that they're slow and stupid
they can fly
i was in a tesla once and yeah when it
goes and you don't hear anything yes
that's weird right that's a weird
feeling it is so let's let's take that
rather than spewing gas into the
atmosphere i think that's a better
i'm sorry for now i got my gas guzzler
what am i supposed to do sell it i'm in
west virginia it's not like we got
charging ports all over the place so i
guess once the charging ports show up
then i'll get a tesla all right chris
enjoy your weekend uh and happy i i mean
i i don't want to look i know they're
i'm not i'm not a climate change denier
no i know that something needs to be
done i just i i know also that it feels
like it's a fight that is going to take
years to win and i don't have the energy
to worry about it especially when i
spend my time fighting fights i can't
win in the nfl i hear you we'll do
p-f-t-o-t on monday have a great weekend
everybody we'll be back on friday with
pfd live big cat will be in the building
for that and
things are still moving around the clock
check us out at profotballtalk.com have
a great day
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports